as a matter of conscious experience the
reality of your life is always now and I
think that this is a liberating truth
about the nature of the human mind in
fact I think there's probably nothing
more important to understand about your
mind than that if you want to be happy
in this world the past is a memory it's
a thought arising in the present the
future is merely anticipated it is
another thought arising now what we
truly have is this moment and this and
we spend most of our Lives forgetting
this truth refuting it fleeing it
overlooking it and the horror is that we
succeed we manage to never really
connect with the present moment and find
fulfillment there because we are
continually hoping to become happy in
the future and the future never arrives
it is always now however much you feel
you need to plan for the future to
anticipate it to mitigate risks the
reality of your life is now even when we
think we're in the present moment we are
in very subtle ways always looking over
its shoulder anticipating what's coming
next we're always solving a problem and
it's possible to Simply drop your
problem if only for a moment and enjoy
whatever is true of your life in the
present